hey everybody i'm fair and cousins in
for david pakman and this is the david
pakman show we've got all kinds of great
stuff coming up today the latest on
afghanistan of course some covet updates
for you and
even a little bit of insight
into what is happening with republican
congressman matt gates and that
investigation and
some other problems that he's having
right here where i'm sitting in
florida's first congressional district
but let's kick things off obviously
still the biggest news in the world
right now
afghanistan
things uh getting worse of course
and here's something interesting that's
happened and this was actually pointed
out by dave weigel
of the washington post where weigel
pointed out over the weekend
that a web page on the rnc's official
website seems to have disappeared
and that website or web page i guess
was the page talking about donald
trump's historic peace deal as they
called it
with the taliban with regards to
afghanistan if you go to that page now
there's just a 404 page not found error
because apparently the republican
national committee doesn't want people
seeing that they're promoting that
ridiculous peace deal that donald trump
allegedly worked out
and there's a couple reasons for that
too so let's dive right into those first
and foremost they don't want any
attention
on what donald trump did as president
with regard to afghanistan and let's be
honest there's a lot
but the peace deal that he allegedly had
worked out with the taliban that was
signed in february of 2020
is the biggest thing they don't want
people to remember
and that's because once you dig down
into the details of this so-called peace
deal you realize how horrible it
actually was and the biggest uh problem
with this peace deal
is that it completely excluded
the afghan government
no leaders from afghanistan were
involved in the drafting of this
and the protections that the united
states agreed to with the taliban did
not extend
to the actual afghanistan
government
the deal only pertained
to u.s troops
and our nato allies in the country that
the taliban
would not attack them in exchange for
the united states agreeing to leave the
country
within 14 months but nowhere
not any part of that agreement did the
taliban say oh by the way we we won't
promise
to not attack the afghanistan government
apparently that was just a major
oversight
of this peace deal
and of course
as soon as the united states leaves
the taliban goes and overthrows the
government of afghanistan
so yeah it's not surprising that they
would want that web page removed from
existence
because they're boasting about it
talking about look what donald trump did
bringing peace to the middle east
with this historic deal
nope
nope another total failure by donald
trump
another reason though that they do not
want this page out there in existence
and i think this is probably the bigger
one
is because they want all the focus right
now
to be on joe biden
that is the goal
make this biden's failure
make this all about his decision
to remove trump's from afghan troops
from afghanistan ignoring the fact that
even just a couple months ago donald
trump was you know screaming at the top
of his lungs
to tell joe biden to get the troops out
of afghanistan
but they have to frame this
as biden's failure because that's the
new talking point
it emerged fast it emerged quick and
based on what we're seeing in the media
tends to be the uh sticking narrative at
this point that this is all joe biden's
fault
and let's obviously be clear about this
that's not the case
this is the fault of four different
administrations
but if you had to lay the blame at
anybody's feet that blame is going to be
squarely at the feet of george w bush
and i will get more into that in just a
little bit but the talking point
from the rnc
from republican officials
from elected officials from donald trump
himself is all about joe biden being a
catastrophic failure
and they're hoping that they can ride
this all the way through the midterms
you know i pointed out yesterday on the
program
that the republicans have had a hell of
a time getting any kind of talking point
to stick about joe biden
they have crafted all these narratives
fox news has tested them out and even
fox news at one point was getting
frustrated because nothing they were
saying or using to attack biden was
resonating with the audience
well this is something that would
resonate
and again as i mentioned fair or not
biden was the president when this
happened so if people are going to blame
somebody they are going to blame him
i don't agree with that assessment at
all
but i also live in reality i've been
doing this long enough you know coming
up on two decades at this point we know
how these things play out
we know where the blame is going to go
and we know the talking points that the
republicans are going to use
and one of the main reasons we know that
is because we're literally already
seeing it happen
on social media in the corporate media
republicans are pushing this non-stop
and they want to keep it that way
they want the focus
to remain on joe biden because that's
the message joe biden
couldn't keep afghanistan safe and if he
can't keep them safe how's he going to
keep you safe
we're already
starting to see the narrative crop up
of oh what does taliban taking over
afghanistan mean for terror attacks here
in the united states
several outlets started reporting
stories like that on monday
they're already trying to pose this as
what is the significant threat that this
will pose to us here in the united
states can biden even keep us safe now
we're right back into that same post 911
mentality
where every time you turn around there's
a boogeyman being pushed on you
by these politicians who are using it
to scare you into submission to scare
you into voting for them
and that's what we're starting to see
now it's disgusting but again it's 100
percent
predictable
this is how they operate this is the way
they craft their narrative this is the
way they sell it to the public
and unfortunately the republican party
is very very good
at selling these narratives in a way
that the democratic party can only ever
dream of being
on issue after issue republicans get out
front on the messaging and that is what
sticks and then the democrats have to
come from behind trying to defend it
debunk it refute it whatever it and
they're never on the offensive and this
narrative has already been lost
it's already been lost
so again
whether you agree with biden's decision
to pull the troops out i do
whether you disagree with it doesn't
matter
the narrative that the media has already
captured is that this is a failure of
the biden administration and republicans
are going to ride that all the way to
the 2022
midterms
i've struggled falling asleep at night
and realized part of it could be because
of the blue light coming from my phone
and computer screens and peer-reviewed
studies have shown that blue light can
suppress the hormone melatonin which can
make it difficult to fall asleep blue
light can disturb your circadian rhythms
but it hasn't been an issue for me since
i discovered blue blocks glasses which
filter out that blue light they're one
of our sponsors a lot of other companies
are mass producing supposed blue light
glasses and factories with no actual
quality standards blue blocks glasses
are made in actual optics labs at their
headquarters in australia they have over
40 stylish frames a prescription version
non-prescription even reading glasses
and for every pair of glasses that blue
blocks sells they give a pair of reading
glasses to someone in need you'll get
twenty percent off when you go to blue
blocks dot com slash pacman the link is
right underneath this video and there's
free shipping worldwide on orders over a
hundred and fifteen dollars